I want to pull up this clip you have of
uh uh of Ronda santis we have this tweet
from Laura lomer he got lumed Ronda
santis gets lered inside his hotel this
is the this is the image that's going
viral it's being memd Ronda sandz
looking shocked as of course Laura lomer
uh confronts him but there's a really
interesting point brought up in your
confrontation a question that was uh
asked by you and another individual
Ronda he looks scared to death already
he really does and that's great
screenshot Ronda santis issued a state
of emergency in in Florida after a major
storm hit there's flooding two days ago
two days ago and uh I didn't know that
you know I'm here it's two days ago we
are in Iowa right now during what they
call a blizzard of the decade a once in
a decade blizzard the businesses didn't
open today we went to like Starbuck was
closed we were able to get some coffee
unfortunately we didn't have any Casper
here with us but we went we tried going
to a Tha food restaurant closed next
door pizza shop closed there's a few
places that are still open we went to a
hotel restaurant to find food to get
lunch because hotels are open eats
delayed by 30 minutes oh Jesus now
here's the point and I'm banned on eats
how do you think I feel so here's here
here here's when I watch this clip of
you I heard that and I went whoa wait
really and I googled I checked out the
state of emergency Ronda santis is the
governor of Florida his State needs him
and instead of being there he is in Iowa
a place right now where let's be honest
the storm has everything shut down he
doesn't need to be here he can campaign
he can be in Florida and then he can he
can remotely do do what he needs to do
but it is shocking to me that a time
where the city is paralyzed by this
blizzard he opted to be in Iowa during
their blizzard instead of Florida it's
even worse than that so he flew to
Florida I think it's uh today's what the
12th so I think it was the 9th if you
check the day the screenshot on the 9th
he flies 9th or the 10th flies to
Tallahassee from Iowa to give his State
of the State address stays for a couple
hours declares a state of emergency
while he's there and then immediately
gets on a plane back to Iowa so you fly
to give a state of the State and he's
getting booed by legislators and
lawmakers who are there in attendance
because uh the town of Tallahassee had
been affected by the storms okay 49 out
of 67 of Florida's counties were
affected by the storms and the tornadoes
and Rhonda santz is polling at 14% in
Iowa 5% in New Hampshire they stopped
all ad spending in New Hampshire and
it's like come on you wasted $300
million of everyone's money
around pretending like you're going to
be president of the United States you're
an absentee Governor cut it out get back
to Florida and do your damn job I'm I'm
I'm I'm I'm sorry I'm just this one
really really pissed me off because I
have I have said I liked him policy-wise
he shouldn't have been running his
campaigns run poorly but his State needs
him right now and and and look I know
that the people are going to come to me
and say Donald Trump did this Donald
Trump did that he went vacation fine by
all means like criticizing any other of
these politicians I will say yes to you
when I see Ronda Sanz do what you just
described La flying fly out and he's in
a state that is undergoing a he's in De
Mo there's a blizzard and he's here
instead of his home state I'm just like
look aside from the fact it was the
wrong move morally he also just lost a
tremendous opportunity to prove he is
the good leader by standing with Florida
and saying to all the people of Iowa
know this as your president I will never
abandon you like I will not abandon the
people of my state
today one done this though right and the
last thing I want to say is he had an
opportunity to actually use this as a
secondary method of maybe this is how he
bows out gracefully by saying I will not
be at the Iowa caucus because my state
needs me I won't abandon them instead
I'm looking at his face the scared face
and I'm like here's a guy who abandoned
his State during a state of emergency to
be third or fourth place like you just
pointed out he's losing he's spent all
this money I'm like this is abject
campaign failure in every possible way
this is you don't Governors don't run
are not supposed to be able to run for
president they've got to step down from
governance in order to do that because
the campaign's so demanding so what did
he do to change that rule so I said that
to him too if you want to play the video
uh we can play it and talk about it or
talk about it and then play it whatever
you want to do Tim but uh essentially
and I talked about this when I was on
your show um a couple months ago right
when I debated the Aging lesbian um Bill
Mitchell shout out to Bill Bill and I
want to clarify too he's the one who
said that and he and and funny guy he he
was in the joke he he rolled with the
punches but that was him who said that
he said it you know can can we play this
clip play CLI explain it yeah all right
uh that was today do we have uh do we
have I don't think we have audio though
got to get audio yeah no audio givee
givee gime all right never mind nope
that's lur on the left well we can wait
till you get audio want to wait till uh
I I think we just got to click the and
we we'll start over start it over start
it over then so uh let's see here um so
this is today want a full
screen I'm
recording time okay thank you hey
Governor thank what are you going to
drop out don't you think you've already
wasted enough of people's money $300
million Governor Des santis why do you
have a bubble wrapped campaign
Ron pretending to get a drink are you
going to be endorsing president Trump
when you drop out the night of the Iowa
caucus or hopefully shortly
after an absentee governor who changed
the law in Florida so that you could run
for president
answer a question Ron I thought you were
never backed down Never Back Down Ron
whatever happened to
that charges against
you there's a state of emergency in your
state why aren't you there there's a
state of emergency in the State of
Florida that you declared into abandoned
Floridian why you hitting me why you
hitting
me you wouldn't be Governor if it wasn't
for president Trump you betrayed
president Trump youve betrayed the
people of Florida and you're going to
lose 14% in Iowa 5% in New hampsh
[Laughter]
Ron you're a nightmare
see
it's S no it gets worse everybody so I'm
here in front of the hotel in West de
Iowa and Rony santz just got lored he
looked petrified honestly I think that
his soul left his body when he saw me
and he's such a coward whatever happened
to Never Back Down Right Never back down
he ran into the hotel convenience Lobby
you know where they sell the little
snacks and the waters and the tampons
and things like that let's just I want
to I want you're here you can tell us
exactly no it's just 30 more seconds
just play it when you said absentee
Governor's eyes s
ran took the elevator up to the nth
floor to run away from me this is a guy
who is too scared to face an independent
journalist Laura Limer he's running a
bubble wrapped insulated campaign
campaign doesn't want to talk to the
people and he runs away he's going to
lose president Trump is going to kick
his ass in Iowa on Monday January 15th
and that's it for Ron you killed your
political career Ron and I hope you're
happy you just got lumed
and now you know what the weather
is like in Iowa today sideways blowing
sow oh and it got crazier uh uh a few
hours ago it was just like total white
out when you said absentee Governor his
that's when his eyes went screenshot and
he was like realized what he was doing
being away from Florida like it's it's
you know what really really shocked me
call I call him I call him you know
why I call him Florida's absentee
Governor I'm not calling him gay right
oh I see I'm saying it's Florida's
absent yeah it's an acronym look Florida
Governor maybe I didn't say that the
right way Florida's absentee Governor
that's r i i was uh I'm I'm disheartened
I'm like here's this guy that a uh two
years ago just just about not even two
years ago I was hanging out to daily
wire crew saying I think he might be the
guy he's got the young energy he's got
the Trump stuff find him Trump hadn't
announced or anything like that we don't
know what he was doing Ronda santis was
the lead in the betting markets M across
the board he was favored to win he's now
below Nikki Haley so and I'm just I'm
I'm sorry look like we've consistently
said he of a ramas swame too in New
Hampshire I mean he's actually in fifth
place in New Hampshire we we've or was
until Chris Chrissy dropped out yeah
we've talked about how
he's oh he's great on policy he's done a
good job in Florida and there's a lot of
things he's done that's that's that that
we can say are good but this is a hell
of a way to end your political career to
leave your state during an emergency to
campaign where you're losing and getting
gloomed well see the yes well maybe he's
trying to do a retribution Arc because
what better way to to fail and then uh
try to make your way out of this hole
that you dug yourself in I mean there's
that possibility well the decision that
he made to only go with corporate media
and to avoid all alt media the basically
as you someone said earlier like he
should have done exactly what fa's done
If he if he had an ounce of Charisma if
he wasn't so deep on the Spectrum he
could actually just engage with all of
the people that are like churning the
culture out in this country but instead
he's avoided us he's now he's getting
lumed and looks like he his pants
when she approached him it's like it's
just devastating to watch I moved to
Florida because of this guy I I'm a
California Refugee I appreciate what he
did as Governor but his campaign has
been disastrous on on a level that I I
can't even really fathom it's it's it's
not just Ron it's also Nikki Okay so
there's arguments to be made for you
know if you're someone like Ronda santis
don't engage if say like Laura is coming
at coming coming at you engage today
though and you can't okay this is the
thing you can't go around calling your
pack Never back down I mean it's so
ridiculous Never back down right just
like I said in the video oh Never Back
Down except with Laura ler right he
won't even do a spaces
with like he's so w that because he
doesn't like us you can't go around
saying that you're a fighter and Say
Never back down and then run he had
every every single confrontation I'm
convinced this stage he had climate
protesters he had climate protesters
today at his event in or yesterday in
ases and he goes you're being rude this
is my time not yours be quiet be quiet I
mean he just acts like a toddler first
of all every time he speaks and secondly
he likes to talk like he's so tough and
even worse you could pull up the Tweet
10 minutes after he got lored he posted
a tweet on pull it up so people can see
he posted a tweet on his uh Ronda santis
account that said something like oh I'll
never run away from anything except me
except me no no it's it's it's i' say
mostly you but did you know that uh
Ronda sanis campaign has banned his uh
people from appearing on Tim cast IRL
yeah for a while now we talked about
that last time I was on it's crazy but
this is what makes V's campaign so so
impressive I I I have never seen anyone
that's willing to talk to he's done my
show with Luke he's done my show solo
he's done Dave Smith he's done
IRL he's done oh right right right no no
I say V he will talk to any anybody and
and it's totally unscripted he he will
take all comers people that are
detractors people that don't like him he
is just he is like it's just purely
through he inviting protesters outside
who are protesting his event to come
inside and start a dialogue with him so
shouts out to individuals like that who
are willing to face criticism who who
are willing to face controversy and have
hard difficult conversations that's what
wins elections and that's what dtis is
not doing he should be doing this show
he should be arguing he should be making
his stand and he's not doing any of that
he does I mean no contentious interviews
are you kidding me you're running a
campaign here talk to the people who of
course represent the people the most The
Independent Media the people on the
ground the people who represent the
people more than the corporate media
that that you keep giving exclusive
interviews to it's a shame that's why I
said when he was in there I said Ron why
are you running a bubble wrap insulated
campaign because Nikki Haley is too they
want to rap these people and bubble wrap
to protect them because everything has
to be scripted every little interaction
Nikki Haley has has town halls and now
she doesn't even take Town Hall
questions anymore whereas V raas swame I
was at his uh his um uh press conference
at the Iowa capital the other day and
he's given a talk about no eminent
domain for private gain and this you
know lady from Cambodia starts
screeching at the top of her lungs and
he says how about this let's make a deal
I'm going to give you the microphone for
60 seconds and you're going to make your
case and then I'm going to tell you why
you're wrong and you know I've never
seen anything like it it's honestly I'm
a trump supporter and I'm for Trump no
one's ever going to change my mind but
it is so impressive it is so impressive
to see the way that V communicates with
opposition here's the big takeway too
and I hope people have have taken note
of this is that because Nikki Haley and
DeSantis took corporate donors it made
it impossible for them to do the media
circuit that V has done because if they
say the things that would be popular in
those audiences their donors are going
to be pissed so they can't do it they've
basically taken the money so they can
buy the ads and they're just going to
have their influencers was try and set
the narrative as to who they are and how
they'll how they'll govern and set their
policies from the highest interest who
paid for them just like we saw with
Ronda Santos's flip-flop on Ukraine
which was the first sign that that I saw
especially after the the Tucker Carlson
interview where he he he bowed down he
cowed down to the corporate media but
but more importantly he took special
interest money and then flipped his own
policies which is something that that I
don't want to see from my political uh
you know leader but I remember back when
was like Ron's doing a great job in
Florida yeah he was he was head of the
PO he did an incredible job in Florida
he did an incredible job with with the
sickness he did an incredible job when
it came to uh people's bodily autonomy
he did an incredible job especially when
it came to countering all this nonsense
when the corporate media was telling
everyone that there was going to be a
genocide in Florida because of his covid
policies and L you think that but
honestly as somebody you now for I
understanding right like you moved to
Florida so absolutely yeah so for people
who saw it from the outside it was all a
farce okay Ronda santis is a Manchurian
Candidate and as we know Fox News has
been grooming him for years now to be
this opposition candidate to Donald
Trump his covid record was no different
than the record of some of these
Democrats it's just the media lied lied
about it I was running for congress in
20120 in Palm Beach County and I was not
able to knock on doors because there
were lockdown orders and you were
threatened with arrest in uh Palm Beach
County for walking on the beach there
were parents that got arrested uh there
were the first time a pastor has ever
been arrested and over 120 years in the
United States happen in Tampa Florida
and he's now I believe supporting uh
president Trump I'm telling you right
now people were lied to about Ronda
Santos's record he pushed the vaccine
he's on video telling everybody that the
vaccines have a 99% Effectiveness rate
and I know people are going to say well
how can you be a hypocrite Trump pushed
the vaccine too Trump pushing the never
forced anybody to get it but it's a
matter of choice and I agree with it I'm
not vaccinated I will never take the
vaccine I refuse to why are we trying to
adjudicate something for 4 years ago
right now just making the point that
he's not a good governor and people need
to stop saying that he had a great
record on Co because it's a lie you can
read his own executive orders that say
I'm locking down the beaches I'm locking
down the restaurants he's a liar he's a
manuri candidate thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 P.M and become a member
over at
timcast.net
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time